good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
monday sadly we need to acknowledge the
space that we're in and we're in a
monday so let's acknowledge it let's
bless it let's make it the best possible
monday we can make it and just cross our
fingers until thursday friday
yeah it sucks that like we spoke so much
about acknowledging the space we were in
when we were in a dead space and of
course and now we have to do it for that
same negative space
that's life by the way like you
literally only acknowledge the space
that you're in like when it's positive
you don't want to acknowledge when it's
negative but here we are acknowledging
both the positive
and the negative okay well let me
present you an idea
what if we acknowledge the space that
we're in and try and focus on like any
positives about the space
what if we acknowledge the space that
we're in and choose to ignore it i think
that's good
no no but like there are some positives
about today first first full day
passover is over that's true i had my
granola bar this morning which i haven't
been able to have
no more binding stomach issues yesterday
i cleaned out the kitchen and i threw
away all the matzah and it was literally
like the best day of my life
yeah so that's a positive about the
space that we're in that's true like i
can have rice for dinner like rice was
so
i actually could go another week dead
serious without like actual bread
pasta sliced bread i i was dying
itching for rice yeah you're addicted to
rice
a hundred percent and you know what you
can have potatoes and fries and like
that wasn't even enough to see
i was like making fries at home um
that's sad
i know well they were fine like they
just weren't good and like i could have
ordered mcdonald's if i wanted to i
don't know last year i was like so into
the potatoes and chips
but this year not so much it wasn't
enough for me dayenu
it was not enough for me and i just
missed rice so much and i cannot wait to
go out to like dinner and have like
sushi
yeah that's really exciting also
acknowledging the space that we're in
it's a beautiful day
it is a beautiful day it's 55 degrees it
was a chilly weekend it was also ben's
birthday so we're just
we're celebrating a lot of simchot so i
think
there's plenty of positives in the space
to currently acknowledge and also
acknowledging the space that we're in
and kicking off ben's birthday he kicked
off like the birthday season yeah
for our family so many birthdays in the
next three months
and zach shapiro zach weinred margo
ashrae
are all in may right yeah they're all in
one week yeah it's very tight we got co
420
stop i can't even talk about the fact
that theo's turning four because like i
literally will end up opening one of
these windows and throwing myself out of
it
that's crazy four is grown
like do you want me to cry like
seriously okay i'm to move on to another
anniversary celebration toast
anniversary coming up is it our fourth
year or third
third okay i was gonna age us we're
going into our fourth uh
you know what like anniversary news
canceled we started 20 2018 to 2019
2019 to 2020 2020 to 2021 is our third
anniversary
okay yeah but we're going into year four
yeah yeah but which is
crazy it came up on my timehop because
like i guess two years ago we threw an
anniversary party
which we should make more well obviously
not this year or last year but
we need to make sure we continue that
tradition of throwing an anniversary
party and inviting all of our friends
and colleagues no
i think that we will i'm so glad that we
did it then because we have all the
memories to look back on and we were
getting
amazing photos [ __ ] snacks yeah we
were looking like we just like woke up
and decided to be snatched yeah and we
woke up and chose to snatch wigs
actually no like choosing snatchiness
takes months of preparation
years of eternity um but yes it is our
third year anniversary so for those who
are new for those who've been here from
the beginning
we love and appreciate you and thank you
for listening to the show yeah so it's
always a new time and i do feel like
with passover it is signaling like
the rebirth the new season and spring
has sprung
but i feel like with new season of toast
like we're really also celebrating
the new season yeah i mean we do seasons
but they start in like the beginning of
the year but season like metaphorically
yes of course of course of course yes
of course so that's a good stuff about
the space that we're in yeah we also
have a great show of course so that's
always important to acknowledge
we have a real housewives of atlanta
recap at the end of the show and i don't
have much to say but um
i'll do my best yeah and we have the
fast five and did you watch any other
stuff this weekend
no or read anything no i
[ __ ] this should come as a shock to no
one i was pretty much on a three-day
bender
have not stopped drinking since the
weekend started and
i'm i'm curious if other people are
struggling with this kind of post
pandemic fatigue issue because like for
me
in the last like months since you know
vaccines have started to roll out and
the city is really pretty much open
i have been going out so much and like
partying so much
and it's like wearing on me but like
i feel this like inane i don't know if
that's right weird like this
internal guilt to like keep going out
because i couldn't go out for so long
but like i'm tired too and like i don't
want to turn down plans
because i know like what me a year ago
would be dying to say yes to these plans
but my body like if i if i were to
listen to my body my body would say stay
the [ __ ] side
but i'm listening to my head i think
that you should you can't compare like
right now to a year ago
go at your own pace listen to your body
acknowledge the space that you're in
and still use your judgment you don't
have to all of a sudden go to everything
that's not who you are
no i've been dancing at every party you
know you can't metaphorically
you can't dance at every wedding that's
the truth but you haven't been
to a wedding in so long like so maybe
you should yeah
so that's currently what i'm doing i
would say pace yourself you know your
body better than anyone
just listen to it yeah if i'm listening
to her right now she's mad at me for
like what we did this weekend like
no sleep she was always mad club another
club
bus you know she was always mad about
yeah you know
that's also she never feels good though
that's part of the as long as you're
having fun at the things that you're
doing you're always gonna have to pay
the price
yeah no and i saw some great celebrities
this weekend like out and about in town
i saw zane and gigi
and so tall so skinny so in love nice
yeah they were like literally huddled
over each other the whole time
nobody in sight but that's okay because
i'm sure they have a nanny
parents i think they can afford one
piano yeah no it was cute it was
actually just like crazy to be in the
presence of like two people so famous
i was thinking to myself like this is
you know maybe the closest i'll get to a
one direction reunion that's where my
head was at
no i think you'll get closer sometime
yeah i think you'll be at like a concert
once like harry styles and like niall is
there
yeah you know i actually been thinking a
lot about niall horan i'm so glad you
brought that up
because i've been really really even
though quarantine is over i've been
really spending a lot of time inside the
quarantine playlist which is such a
fabulous place to be
and a couple days ago i was listening to
that song that he wrote for some music
music
when nothing's out of reach
it feels like i'm finally free
finally free from the movie small foot
small foot thank you and so i was
listening to it and then it just like
caused me to
just go back and appreciate some of
niall horn's music and if you would have
told me like the day that one direction
broke up
that nile horn out of all them in my
opinion
would have some of the most popular and
arguably
best music out of all the soloists in
one direction like you would have
like i never would have believed you
like yes harry's is more critically
acclaimed
more award-winning but i think niles is
way more like accessible pop music
radio hits and he's really undervalued
in the music industry i think
yeah well i'm glad that that you're
seeing him everyone deserves to be seen
and i
i see nile horn i actually saw him in
concert literally i saw him
you have seen him for a while i've seen
him i have laid eyes and
um it was a great night it was the
flicker world tour they
we bought merch it said flickr but it
looked like it said [ __ ] because the l
and the
l and i like were connected so snitch
and i had a good laugh about that
that's a great t-shirt to have a [ __ ]
t-shirt and
it was really a great night and also it
was like a split concert i wouldn't say
one was opening for the other because it
didn't feel that way with maron morris
oh that is good so we just had a great
night i do find it interesting when
um people go on tour together they don't
like open for each other they go on tour
together and it's like
what is the better slot first or last
last interesting
well and i'm sure like the argue like
when you're first you can't acknowledge
that space so you're gonna
make the argument that it's better you
get to go home earlier you know you get
to be performing when it's like light
out which is just like better lighting
um
but you can't avoid the fact that like
second is because headliner
is the second well i was watching joan
rivers documentary recently for like the
50th time and she
amongst the million things she was doing
she did a show in atlantic city she
co-wrote
with don rickles and she was like when
we first started like i asked to go
first because like i wanted to get home
first and so she's like
everyone thinks like don rickles has a
better spot but i actually have the
better spot right so i think it could go
both ways
but i also think if two people are going
on tour 50 50 like how come and
and the second slot is the better slot
and they're equally big artists like why
don't they switch off every night
and by the way usually they bring out
the second artist like i'm sure marin
seem blind right yes so you have to wait
you have to wait you can go home anyway
so yes it actually
sucks to go first but that song seeing
blind is
so good yeah also just while we're on
the subject because you brought up small
foot um
kids movies i just have an update about
descendants something that i learned
about descendants four
descendants for the royal wedding is
going to be animated
animated movie wait what like and
cartoon
cartoon i don't understand cartoon the
characters are like voicing their
characters
and it's going to be cartoon like but is
it like a
of the story yeah because they're like
engaged and now it's a royal wedding
no and you know what it is you know what
it is it's a disgrace is what it is yeah
you can't just
change mid-franchise from animated from
real life to animating no
it's so disgraceful it's so hurtful and
like we put up with a lot with
descendants three and you do this on
number four
that's [ __ ] asked for this that's
weird kenny ortega should know better
it's sick the whole thing sick sick in
the head
so i was so excited last week and i'm no
longer excited i'm sorry for you that
that's been taken away it's okay because
i didn't know like i'm just gonna go
back to a few days ago where i didn't
even know descendants four was like
two words i would put together well
actually speaking of franchises ben
um because it was his birthday and like
you know you can't say no to someone on
their birthday he's been like begging me
to watch harry potter with him because
like he's obsessed like he read the
books he loves the movies and i
obviously say no
but i literally could not say no to him
on his birthday so we watched it like on
saturday afternoon
and we had um he chose one because i
said don't show me one where like
the kids when they're young they're cute
then there's a few movies where they're
like a little weird looking because
they're going through puberty and then
they like grow up to look like
themselves
and i'm like don't show me any like the
puberty ones like i hate watching kids
go through puberty like bran stark
syndrome i don't like it
and we watched number four and i have to
say
i love franchises like in twilight like
and i think a lot of them get bad
reputations
i have to say like this movie was a
piece of [ __ ] like and i don't mean to
offend like the harry potter community
but oh my god like that's your hero like
literally the worst movie of all time
and it never ended and i'm saying that
knowing that you know one of the main
characters in the
prison no what was the movie called i
don't know
ask about the one that you watched
prisoner of azkaban but that's not
number four
stone goblet of fire thank you um do you
know who the main character is in goblet
of fire
who i'll give you one clue edward cullen
robert pattinson yes he's in it he's
literally the star
so you must have loved it you would
think because he was young and
so cute like so handsome that's been
like 16 like
you could tell he was going to grow up
to be like you know the blood sucking
vampire of our dreams but he was just
like
had this youth and this innocence and i
couldn't believe it so i was like
actually into the movie at first but oh
my god they dragged it out so long and
it was
so bad wow i mean i would never think
that you would like it and i feel like
if you ever would like it you really do
need to watch it from the beginning to
care at all
no no i've seen sorcerer's stone i saw
the first
i think i saw the first three and two i
saw the third one
and i found it to be so scary like there
was a big tree and the campers were
quaking
and i was just like i don't watch scary
movies yeah the [ __ ] is this so
i am not a harry potter pirate or stan
harry potter
i think that if i took the time to watch
each movie now as an adult with maybe
like i could handle it
um i'm sure i would find it to be really
good i'm sure it's like no i'm telling
you
like there is a myth like it's not good
really
like i can't believe people who like
that like judge us for watching twilight
like
now having seen like a lot of harry
potter and
all of twilight like it like bothers me
that like
harry potter is like critically
acclaimed and like twilight is like
considered like you know trash
i've never compared the two like to me
when i'm thinking about harry potter
it's
i'm just i'm like reminded of game of
thrones yes me as well um so how many
movies did you watch
one okay but i've seen three so now i've
seen four out of six what do people say
is the best movie
i feel like the early ones
people really like the first one
oh everyone really enjoys last two
unfortunately like they just lost me on
number four and i will not be making it
to five and six yeah but you know which
one i did like
number seven love number seven is that a
story today
no it's not so let's just talk about him
okay we talk about number seven all the
time here on the toast and again
it's really niche gen z drama so let us
explain it to you from an old person's
perspective
and we have explained it and it's not
drama it's like the most it's not drama
sorry
it's um news yeah so this video had went
viral on tech talk and we've spoken
about it a lot of times we posted it to
our instagram and we'll re-up it later
today in our instagram stories
because it was just like this pure video
of like this football team high school
football team in michigan like
celebrating after a win and i guess like
their
you know um tradition is to sing eeny
meeny miny moe lover by justin bieber
featuring sean kingston
and it was just like a hilarious video
that went viral because it was so
precious and
the quarterback i assume was number
seven he was
kind of the star of the video and he
just looked like so cute and everyone
like all these 30 year olds were like
who was this
you know 17 year old who's making our
heart flutter and
so he's just like the video went viral
and he's just been like living his life
is like a viral sensation he's actually
going to harvard to play football like
he's really good
um i found out literally a few days ago
and i think it like just happened
that he is dating kendall vertez
from dance moms jill's daughter i know
we all remember jill's daughter
yeah big deal huge so i never watched
dance moms so i'm glad you didn't no
so i don't know kendall i'm so sorry to
disappoint you
no no don't be sorry like you have a
journey ahead of you
i think i would like it at this point oh
my god really you
would love it it's twisted like it's
so excuse me
i'm alive am i yes okay
it's so good and there's so many stars
born
chloe lucasiak who is a toaster maddie
ziegler of course kenzie
nya like there's just it's so [ __ ]
good and honestly
you should watch it if if not for any
other reason then just
get to know principal holly okay she is
really the only one with her head
screwed on straight okay maybe i will
and then oh my god in the beginning like
the whole candy apple drama jackie you
will die like it's so [ __ ] funny
okay and the dances like i actually
think it's interesting to watch they're
actually like really good dancers yeah
that i didn't know
yeah it's good so number seven
oh sorry is dating kendall so kendall
wasn't i believe a part of the original
cast she came in
um a little later on and she was very
good like a major threat
like the pyramid was quaking you'll
understand that reference in a few days
okay and so how do you feel about the
relationship
everything like i think it's i love an
age-appropriate relationship i love like
two you know instagram stars finding
love i think they're probably um
he's from michigan and she if she was on
she has to live in pittsburgh because
that's where abby lee dance company was
um founded yes and i think
i think it's like a good i really do
think it's a good match that's really
cute
and i have to say like after i posted
about it on my stories i did find out
that riley vertez kendall's
sister is a big-ass toaster and she kind
of gave me like some tea and she just
said like they're
really happy together and like i'm so
happy for them that is so cute i'm
so happy that for them i'm so happy for
number seven like he has stayed in my
heart and in my mind
ever since the video and so to hear this
great news
plus he's going to harvard like no i
know he would love to see it and like i
feel like he could have dated like
anyone you know and he could have went
for like an
obvious like la girl but the fact that
he like i don't know
i don't know kendall at all but i just
feel like she's a nice like hometown gal
and i feel like she's down to earth
again
don't know anything about her but i just
get that vibe from her instagram so i
think it's really cool that like he
chose
her and she chose him and they are like
gonna live happily ever after together
and i would like to be the godmother of
their children yeah they chose each
other
just like the ocho's mcplant theo is
eating the plant this plant is actually
while beautiful proving to be a little
bit of a hindrance on our production
you know what we need we need a plant
that hangs from the wall yeah
not one on the floor theo cause can i
hear come here my angel boy
come on he goes hard for mcplant come
here
there he comes give me your mind
and how's that how's theo doing today
he's doing good like really feeling
strong
thinking did he watch bruce on the
episode
uh he did not he felt hurt that he was
kicked out of the studio because
of his cousin yeah but you know like
everyone deserves a little shine
it's true we all are really i think
we're all really good singers we
all sing a lot that's the best [ __ ]
video that victoria justice video
i agree um okay okay i feel like we've
deleted long enough i feel like we've
caught up
and now it is time to get into the fast
side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's definitely true tracks higher
and first time
but in honor of brew to do not being
here i have the next best thing
today's episode is brought to you by
bruce the official toothbrush of the
morning toast
everyone's gotten on the bruce train if
you are not on you are missing it
the train is leaving the station it is
the most reasonably priced
most efficient electric toothbrush on
the market some electric toothbrushes
have the gall the
audacity to charge over two hundred
dollars not british
they deliver a premium electric
toothbrush for a very reasonable price
and it's so sleek and elegant you're
gonna feel like kim kardashian like no
clutter no mess it's just like
everything of the sort
so the brush itself has six unique modes
that you can customize uh your brushing
experience
the battery life lasts four weeks it
comes with a magnetic charging stance
it's very like elegant elon musk very
you know futuristic
and it comes with a compact travel case
they also offer a subscription program
now
so you never forget to change your brush
head again bruce will ship you new
replacement heads every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head
which can lead to bad breath and other
oral problems
um the design is very sleek the brushes
the brush electric toothbrush has a
modern aesthetically pleasing design
it comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter
if you want to get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit and the refill plan
use the promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15
off using promo code toast.brush.com
you can trust jackie and i and you can
trust the thousands of toasters who have
switched to bruce
in the last couple months and are just
so grateful for the elevated experience
yes love bruce sign on
get a bruce okay are you ready for our
first story
we need to talk about this bridgeton
breakout star reggie jean page
aka the duke of hastings will not appear
in season two
why but why so the bridgerton official
account
um penned a letter by lady whistle down
saying that it was a great announcement
it was a great announcement it was in
lady whistleblown's tongue it was the
best they could have given us like bad
news
yes letting us know that he will not be
in season two now on the one hand it's
not a huge deal because season two
is follows a different bridgerton child
we will be following
daphne's brother the vi count and it's
based on the book the viking who love me
whereas the first
season was based on the book the duke
and i so he
each season is not meant to be about
phoebe yes it's
all going to did i call her daphne i
think
her real name is phoebe oh okay i think
her real name is pb and her name is
daphne in the show right okay okay
cool cool um
yeah so they wouldn't be the focal point
of season two but of course like just
like the vi count was in season one like
you know we'll get some action from
the siblings in season two so let me say
this
when it came to the second movie i kind
of assumed
we might like never see phoebe and simon
or daphne and simon again like
on maybe like one season like they go to
their house or something like to me
they're gonna live in the country right
like they have this whole life
so i thought that neither one of them
would be in the show period well i think
that like they'll be in the show in
in the sense that it'll be the london
season the duke and the duchess
are gonna come to the parties and the
fact that the vicon's sister is a
duchess like helps them in the marriage
market so it's just like
they're not stars and i'm sure they'll
have an easy job of
writing the show without the duke of
hastings being present
but like it would have been a treat to
see them everybody fell in love with
them
no it's so bizarre like he must have
gotten a huge
gig yeah so i mean i think that's
probably what it is and definitely
doesn't want to like commit to
more seasons of this show he's a huge
star now he
probably is commanding major roles and
to do a little cameo
in this next season isn't worth his time
which i understand i don't know
i don't know if i understand i think
there's a very delicate thing in
hollywood like with the thing that made
you famous a lot of people like run from
it some people lean into it
and i think yes it made him a huge star
but
it could have been like a flash in the
pan it really could have i think maybe
committing to one maybe two more seasons
like wouldn't have been the worst thing
for him but that's just
that's just my business perspective i
personally agree because i'm just like
you know
nostalgic like that yeah but i'm sure he
has some great roles lined up
it's just going to be sad it's sad for
the fans that we don't get to see him
yeah no and
i as much as i'm sure the new season of
bridgerton is going to be good like i
really am here for like
the simon and daphne story i know but
we're
like the ship that like i know has
sailed no
completely like they're so they got
their happy they're gonna have like
season two has actually a lot to live up
to because it's like a whole new
storyline
and season one is so beloved which
brother is it the older one the one who
goes to those parties
the older one okay the one who was in
love with the opera singer
right got it yeah yeah yeah he's the vi
count there can only be one by country
and he's older
and he's a by accountant who loved her
yeah i really didn't like him or his
sideburns
no i really didn't like him because he
was just like not being good at his job
he was unlikable as [ __ ]
yeah no and he wanted daphne to marry
like that nasty
nigel yeah and she was the jewel of the
season
the diamond of the season makes no
[ __ ] sense makes no [ __ ] he's
gonna have a lot to answer for in season
two
yeah you know now that we're taking the
time to get to know him which nobody
asked for
no i want to know why you wanted daphne
to marry nigel yeah
i'm excited just for like a new season
of something like we can all be excited
about
but also the vi count was good friends
with the duke of hastings so like in his
pursuit of marriage like he could have
gotten marital advice
from the duke but wouldn't he lean on
his friend
there's just gonna be a couple plot
holes married friend and brother-in-law
right who's gonna give him sage wisdom
yeah he doesn't have a father
his father passed away he's like there's
gonna be a gap for sure
for sure so devastating news for simon
the duke of hastings
but we wish you well on your journey to
megastardom
yes that is very true now from for some
sad news
dmx has been hospitalized in new york
terrible
um he's been admitted to a new york
hospital following a reported drug
overdose
on life support like it's really severe
yes the 50 year old rapper
um experienced a heart attack triggered
by an od tmz reports on saturday dmx's
representatives confirmed to billboard
that the rapper is currently
hospitalized and as of saturday night
dmx is on life support rep said a source
had told tmz earlier in the day
that um the yonkers bred mc who has a
long history with drug abuse
had some brain activity while another
source said he was in a vegetative state
oh my god
yeah well wishing him the best yeah this
is a developing story
yeah but very scary very sad very scary
very sad sending love to his family
like truly that's so scary yeah
like wow so picking back up
travis barker joins girlfriend kourtney
kardashian's
family for easter by the way this
kardashian easter was one of their best
right that's what really what i wanted
to talk about kardashian easter came
again
palm springs was shook to the core
everyone was out in full force including
travis barker joining his girlfriend
courtney
courtney called him her boyfriend on a
tick tock so alabama barker with the
premium content
we already knew but now for me like i
didn't need a confirmation like
the kids hanging out together like
they're obviously dating and they're
obviously pretty serious
yeah and i know it's just like something
so juvenile when you like finally call
someone your boyfriend girlfriend where
like
makes it real even for the fans 100 so
i'm living for it i'm so happy i'm happy
for courtney her stock continues to rise
in my book
no i know like i'm actually like quaking
because my entire kind of
belief system like has been turned
around because like i'm
obsessed with courtney and travis parker
like to the point where like i think
about them all the time
yeah no it's it's so good i don't want
to think about it too much because i
don't want to like jinx it i know
so i'm just gonna let time pass and then
be like oh it's been months they're
still together but like were his kids in
palm springs because i believe that they
were
you oh i saw a tick tock of travis in a
pool with his son
and it just like looked like the
kardashian pool well that would be
beautiful
that i know but like how big is that
house they have that many i know it's
really big no
i think there's so many people there's
so many people that each require a
master bedroom
plus they have kids like well there's
definitely i think i remember seeing
like a huge room with like bunk beds
like for all the kids like there's a
kid's room
i think there's literally one room for
the kids except maybe some of the older
ones like alabama probably gets like a
regular room
yeah but still i had the same thought
like every like kylie's not just going
to be sleeping in some guest room
neither is kim i'm sure all the bedrooms
are like master suites they have like
ensuites they have bathtubs like i'm
sure they're all
but like how many are there okay well
chris
chris and corey kim kim chloe and
tristan
travison courtney kendall kylie kylie so
that's
six rooms just family yeah but then if
they have the bunk room for the camera
one room for the kids
maybe there's two then there needs to be
a room for a journey
yeah no yeah nanny and like the adult
kids like alabama there's probably just
like a regular guest room
so i would say that in order to stay
comfortably they need 10 rooms
yeah yeah rob was there
sorry oh my god for so many people talk
completely about rob rob 11 rooms like
that is a lot but yeah the truckers for
rob are out
no like wait wait wait call an ambulance
collin admins calling admins we forgot
about rob kardashian
oh i hope everything's okay hang on guys
you're not getting pulled over it's just
wow it's been a while
but not for me we're muted so
now we're not
okay we're back okay we're back sorry
about that there was a little uh
kerfuffle outside
so yes the logistics of this easter
weekend like did keep me up at night
because i was just like confused like
where are they all sleeping like maybe
there's a loca like a local hotel some
people see it out like i don't know
yeah no and also i feel like sometimes
when kylie goes she leaves the same
night but she slept over because we had
daytime looks and then we had like next
day easter pleni vibes no and like
everyone like everyone was there for the
weekend so like make it make sense
maybe they got two houses yeah maybe
they like run to the one next door
yeah i think that's good yeah there's no
way this house accommodated this entire
family and even if it did like they're
too rich to like be sleeping on top of
each other for the whole weekend
plus glam plus for all the campers
assistants
assistants all the campers it's not just
one nanny no and like literally like
how would even their cars fit in the
driveway like i'm just so concerned
about all of these things
yeah no like chef chef yeah no it makes
no [ __ ] sense
so i think they rented another house in
the community
got it i would love some follow-ups to
this particular conundrum but beyond
that
they gave us so much content like
chris's gifts for all the
so beautiful for all the men was
actually really interesting in terms of
who was
um included can you pull up the picture
tristan got golf clubs
the clubs okay scott was noticeably
absent
clubs kris jenner rob kardashian khloe
kardashian kendall jenner kylie jenner
kim kardashian
kourtney kardashian then there's a pair
of clubs to the left that i can't to the
right that i can't see
um i saw one with all the guys oh i
didn't see that one i think i saw travis
scott tristan thompson
rob kardashian i'm googling
kardashian i didn't see travis i did not
see travis
you didn't see travis no but i just
thought i just remember thinking like oh
that's an interesting group of men
in terms of the golf clubs oh can you
find it
travis posted a photo of clubs that
looked like they were part of the lineup
no no no hold on we just i saw it hold
on
this is too important just give us one
moment
who got got who got clubs right i just
think it'll really kind of
blow this thing wide open they love golf
well they're in palm springs like
literally what else do you do and also
chris jenner says that the golf course
is a great place to meet a guy
who got them travis travis got clubs
yeah no oh and by the way they also all
got um
golf carts yes like what a gift
no and it's like it's just easter no i
know but like
this is probably like the most low-key
gift chris jenner's ever getting
yeah totally it's bothering me so much
like why can't i find it
i swear i saw it kris jenner golf clubs
i just i'm not letting this go someone
will also let us know
yeah i know but i just wanted to discuss
was it here okay maybe maybe then i'm
making it up if i can't find it like
that's probably more like it but i
wishful thinking i had a dream
i swear in my life i saw like a travis
scott one
oh that's confusing travis scott travis
barker
oh i didn't even think of that either
they have two travis's in the family the
travis
the trevi okay whatever what i was gonna
say was though justice for scott because
it appears as though he was left out of
this weekend
well you know what like if you want to
be with amelia in miami and like dating
underage girls then go and do that but
you just can't have it both
i completely you can't get to be like
the family friendly guy and also the guy
who dates 18 year olds i completely
agree
yeah i'm not even mad about it well by
the way i literally could not even find
it
so please okay and then are you ready to
move on
like i don't think i'll ever be ready to
officially move on from this particular
story
yeah but for the sake of our show yes
yeah but we could talk about it later
like you and i
okay you can move on i'm just like no
this next story i need your i need your
full attention because it was something
that you referenced earlier
but pregnant lauren burnham and ari
linda jr are planning to move to hawaii
that's crazy they are moving to hawaii
they said revealing that their family
will soon be residing on the island of
maui
they uploaded an eight-minute tour of
their new digs on youtube the hillside
home is beach adjacent and features a
deck
four bedrooms and two bathrooms we're
going to make all these memories here
we're going to have the best life it's
going to be like the perfect spot trees
our little babies it's going to be cool
already said in the video this is like a
dream for us that is so cute first of
all they are just like
i'm still waiting on you know the
apology for bachelor nation to the lion
dyke family because
they're like some of my favorites who
just like are not thirsty at all like
they just live their life in scottsdale
soon to be hawaii
i'm really really happy for them um and
i really commend people who can just
like
you know throw caution to the wind and
just like move to hawaii you know like
i wish i was like that no and it's like
i thought they were living the life of
riley
in scottsdale but like no it's just
gonna keep getting better i do feel like
they're always in hawaii they got
married in hawaii they have a connection
i saw i follow one if not both of them i
saw that they were in hawaii like making
content and like saying they had
something to reveal
they were obviously like purchasing
their home yeah no so i but i didn't
like
click i didn't i didn't fall i didn't
fall for the clickbait but i should have
because it was like it was very
interesting
they're moving to hawaii like i'm going
to watch this home tour i find that
really interesting
and i'm really happy for them i just
like really like them i think they're
really nice people
yeah i agree and their family's growing
and
where about what a better place than to
be born on the beach like hello
yeah and they're expecting twins oh cute
she'll be a family of five
yeah in a four-bedroom house oh don't
talk to the chris jenner
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story it's a little donut news
the fifth and final story yeah the
fifth and final story
it's the final story
thank you krispy kreme debuts oreo
glazed donuts for the first time take a
look at these bad boys
oh yeah no they sound better than they
look
okay can i tell you what i was thinking
before you brewed it with that photo
like donut
oreo donut no i was just kind of
thinking
the same like glazed doughnut but the
glaze is like an oreo glaze so it's
still just like a plain doughnut oh it's
like a little bit but it's like a
cookies and cream glazes
what you just showed me looks like no
offense because i love the endemins
brand
but those box of 12 donuts they have
with the chocolate covered the brown
sugar like
they're really subpar and they look like
the chocolate covered ones
yeah i totally agree we'll post a
picture of the krispy kreme donuts on
our instagram do not worry about it
sounds better than it looks can i see it
again
yeah there's too much going on i don't
understand what i'm looking at okay
here's what's a donut yes you are
looking at those hostess-like donuts
that are like
the chocolate on the outside but it's
like a crust and it's not pre-made
honestly i thought i really expected
mike tubagari
whatever his name was to do more what
was his name
mike tulsi mike tullerberg let's just go
look at our episode title
oh yeah it was definitely my cattle's
tail oh my cattle field something like
that yeah
hold on my way mike tatler this episode
requires like the most
research okay mike tattersfield you are
close
um mike tattersfield like do better this
is
not [ __ ] it at all okay so not only
it has that like hostess look on the
outside
it's like a shell of hard chocolate on
the outside of a plain doughnut
and then the inside um is like stuffed
with a
crazy filling like filling like so sick
i will
try it but probably not like it so the
donut chain is partnered with oreo to
create two brand new treats oh there's
two
the iconic glazed waterfall will be
transformed to covered donuts in a rich
cookies and cream coating oh that's what
i just said
that's what we want the two limited
edition donuts have also been added to
the menu the oreo glaze donut
that's what i just said and the oreo
cookie over the top doughnut
so there's a doughnut with a cookie
maybe just the photos they took are bad
yeah these are bad promo photos the
former's the former is covered in the
new glaze stuffed with cookies and
krispy kreme signature cream
then topped with crumbled oreo pieces
and an icing drizzle
the latter is topped with cream and
chocolate icing when finished with an
oreo cookie is anyone like confused
and confounded three donuts they also
have the same no like this is just so
many descriptors for a donut i know and
i
i will try it of course um but i just
want to say i'm disappointed in the
photos
but speaking of krispy kreme which has
been just like the topic of discussion
for the last week
since passover is over we're having a
delivery from corporate yeah that's
right they saw our episode
and we're gonna be doing a mukbang on
our youtube
we also got the tall house chocolate pie
from beverly hills
cafe that we raved about last week
literally there's one remaining beverly
hills cafe in miami lakes
and you and i um like spoke about it
obviously and i got reached out to
by every single person who worked there
uh who's ever worked there who owns it
who claims to own it like every single
person
we got ourselves the tall house cookie
pie so that puts the krispy kreme
delivery will be us
like a sensational mukbang and you
better subscribe
to patreon.com the morning toast we have
some good stuff coming up this month i'm
actually really excited me too
um okay those were the past five stories
i feel as though you needed to know them
debatable debatable definitely the
bridgeton of it all and definitely the
palm springs kris jenner of it all but
i think other than that oh dmx too but i
had already known that um
they were great you could have lived
without today's episode
no i just like to talk so whatever same
but let's talk about real housewives of
atlanta and then i want to talk about
all the other
[ __ ] i watch sure so real houses of
atlanta we wrapped up our trip
in um new orleans and i actually
um felt bad for joe like her whole trip
went to [ __ ] and she tried really hard
to like make it a nice trip and i think
in the beginning it was
but it got overrun by the drama and
honestly i'm like the biggest marlow fan
but like i don't know what the hell
she's doing no i mean she was
so all over the place all over the place
she said she was drunk so like maybe we
should just leave it at that but
no but also like next week did you watch
a preview
what's happening they had said that they
heard from someone
that marlo got liposuction and that's
why she was like said her back was
hurting her she didn't go to like half
of the events
yeah actually like it's a decent theory
and so maybe she was just like out of
sorts because she was acting a fool like
why am i being put in the middle while
literally like firmly placing herself in
the middle when nobody put her in the
middle no she was
being crazy and when she was like taking
the picture she's like move in face like
when they showed the flashback i was
like moving
fakes that was funny right no it's funny
but she was just being mean to everyone
yeah she was like
on one so i think she said that it was
the patrons like maybe she was
drunk maybe her back like i don't know
but i feel like she doesn't stand by
that i hope not because like she's
usually
like pretty like i feel good
following her but i was like what are
you doing like and she really did make a
whole scene in front of bigfrida
right but sometimes you're on a trip and
like things
just go hey why are there crazy like a
night that's like
weird and crazy haywire yeah yeah i
completely agree
like drunk and hungover and
jet lag and cabin fever yeah and it's
just like
things go south i agree with you but
what
what i feel so you know kind of proud of
is like since i
started watching atlanta like i've
always without a doubt like blindly
followed miss porsche williams and after
last night's episode i just felt like
even more
cemented in that feeling and like so
proud of my decision because not only is
she so funny like
she just makes me laugh so much when she
was going toe-to-toe with kenya and like
giving kenya nothing just being like
yeah yeah you're jealous like i was
living for it because it was driving
kenya
up a [ __ ] wall i'm like i just really
can't stand kenya and i think porsche is
like the only one who knows how to fight
with her
and i was just living living for the
whole scene like her not giving porsha
like in
her not giving ken yet like an inch whoa
he's not he was like about to fall off
right
let him like he needs to learn no no no
i will never know yes i agree and then
like
by the end because porsha didn't give
kanye the reaction that she wanted it's
like wait so kenya what did you want
from all of this
no and it's like she's what do you want
portia to say that she [ __ ] bolo
and literally kenny's like no i mean i
don't care but like stop lying but you
do care i don't care it's so obvious
that porsche
it's giving me like vibes from like
brandy and denise like
it's obvious that they [ __ ] but like the
point is is that it's none of our
business and it's certainly not fodder
for the tv show
i totally agree so it's the same exact
situation of course
portia [ __ ] bolo like she's a single
woman why shouldn't she
who cares it's none of our business and
she obviously didn't want to brought up
and
candy who i now have so much respect for
is the only person who really
understands what's going on
candy was right next door kenny knows
she was [ __ ] bolo and probably tanya
was in there too
candy says it's nobody's business yeah
and candy is unwavering
in her refusal to talk about it which i
really appreciate
and respect i completely agree i love
that her and portia just like
fled the [ __ ] state and oh my god
like
when they when the lights went out and
they got stuck there and then like they
go to commercial break and then they're
just like magically home like how do
they get home no
i know i think they had to stay probably
for like three extra days like it was a
bad storm
i want to know how long if they like had
to move flights and stuff but i feel
like if they did they would have shown
it
yeah i don't know i don't know i just
like i'm so portia like get me out of
here one because i'm
not having a good time and two because
there's a storm like i'm not being stuck
here with these girls no i was literally
like having anxiety thinking about
if i was stuck like on a vacation like
yeah you could just stay in your room
and like do your thing
i would just like want to be home so
badly so
badly i've made the decision now like
that i feel like we're enough of the
season and like i
really like drew yeah i think she's like
a good time gal she's fun
she did her best planning the trip but
like when kenya was like in the
confessionals like
this trip sucks like south carolina i
win i was like oh my god i cannot no
one's even comparing the two
yeah i just can't stand her
i know you can't and where has brooklyn
been
i don't know we didn't like she said she
was going to check on her at one point
in the episode
yeah but like we didn't literally didn't
see brooklyn the whole episode yeah but
like i didn't think we were going like i
think she's just trying to
be able to do it all no i know but like
on the previous trip where she brought
brooklyn like brooklyn was like the
center of the whole thing
i guess i just like haven't even seen
her like in the bedroom like hanging out
in the back
yeah maybe she's in a different way i
think she's in a different room like
chris shannon's house yes
right it all comes back to chris
jenner's house yeah next week does look
really good though
yes i'm curious about this whole
liposuction ordeal like where did marlo
go like are they taking appointments you
know
100 100 percent
um okay other stuff that i watched this
weekend that i just want to share with
the class so i told you i watched the
movie elizabeth last week and i really
didn't like it
so i watched the other bowling girl
finally um because i really liked the
book and while the movie was good and i
can imagine if i had only watched the
movie and not read the book i would have
really liked it
but considering the book was so long and
like everything was really drawn out and
like
took so much time i thought that the
book the movie was really rushed
if i didn't read the book i would have
no idea what's going on you know
so then i started the book mary queen of
scots but it's 800 pages and i was
already like
i did the sample on kindle and i was
just like not sure if i was going to
continue and i was like you know what
there's a movie about this maybe i'll
read the move maybe i'll watch the movie
because just like bowling girl just one
or the other
so i watched the movie mary queen of
scots starring schwarze ronan
sercia ronan and margot robbie cute and
it was
i didn't love the movie but i liked the
story so i was like maybe i'll continue
reading the book so right now i'm still
reading the book but i'm at like eight
percent i don't know if i'm going to
continue because otherwise that will
take up
all of my time um but then last night i
started the show the last tsar which is
about the last
czar of russia nicholas romanov girl you
are just like on a
i'm on a journey which is why like i
can't be watching dance moms no no
i'm telling you like please like
for me like i just first of all i know
you will love it and second of all like
it's really a cultural phenomenon like i
think just like for research purposes
like you need to be more well-versed
in the pyramid in the ability i'm not
good at my job and like
you are but like you could always be
better you know okay
do better i hear you do better i hear
you
i will go on the journey with you like i
will rewatch it it's so [ __ ]
turned like it's so good okay like just
let me give me a few days to like come
out of
what i'm going through right now yeah
and like while i really am happy for you
on this journey like i just like i don't
really agree with it like this whole
like historical figure thing like you
need to get back to watching trash like
let's go back to hallmark like
it's like we need to dumb ourselves down
like this is the morning toast okay no
no i know
and i know that it's like it doesn't
like i spend all these hours watching
all this stuff that like has nothing to
do with the [ __ ]
and like when you bring it up i'm like
happy for you i'm like people don't care
you like about the queen of scots
okay i think some people care because i
get a lot of recommendations and ideas
like a lot i would love to be wrong
please let's add a segment the queen of
scots segment like i would love that
the queen of scott do people want to
hear it i don't know let us know
if you're interested in this historical
journey that i'm on you know maybe i
could spark notes for you guys and we
could all learn a little something yeah
that's true like
me know nothing about history me no
smart
it wouldn't be that bad but i'm just
used to talking about like dumb [ __ ] on
the show
yeah but like i'm still doing my
homework like i'm still watching the
housewives and whatnot
there's nothing on tonight which is such
a joy such a joy it's like after this
last year of like literally watching so
much garbage like i need to be filling
my head with
premium better stuff that's fair that is
a fair point you're right about that
so that's where i'm at also speaking of
books
redheads madness is underway okay let's
talk about it and it's
madness you guys like march madness
yeah and you keep calling it redheads
madness and i'm like what's
it's maddening like i didn't know you
meant like march madness
that makes more sense yeah it's like
march madness for all the redheads books
everyone has been voting in the polls
we're about to hit the semi-finals we
have one poll that's going right
how many books is it we have done 18
books total so now you're at the top
four
yes there's two polls that are finishing
themselves out it looks like i know who
the winners are gonna be and both of
them are
shocking like genuinely shocking i am
shocked by the redheads well so
i was keeping up with it briefly but
i've only read like three or four of the
red heads books so i couldn't vote in
most of the polls
um and i actually had completely forgot
that my book was a choice for the
redheads
so had i known that like i would have
been more invested in like all the
voting and stuff
but you told me yesterday when i spoke
to you that i made it to the semifinals
when like i deadass thought i was not
even gonna like i didn't even know i was
involved in the chart and the fact that
i made it to the top four like if i
don't make it one step further i'll be
so glad like i'm up against maya angelou
like real [ __ ] authors
yeah but again like all of so many of
the books that i thought would be like
straight to the semis out so let me tell
you about your journey
first you were up against the glass
hotel which um
i was probably one of the most literary
books that we chose it was an easy win
everybody hated it like oh god did you
win true and it was it was my choice and
i
i just it was on every list like every
recommendation and i just don't think it
was
it's not what the red heads were into i
got it message received easy win
then you went up against nothing to see
here which you've read which is
amazing loved loved loved loved that
book
you swept the category next
there's a match going on right now
between codename helene and how to fail
at f flirting to
jackie's choices and shockingly to me
it looks like how to fail at flirting is
going to be winning yeah which is what
you'll be going up against next
because if you were going up against
codename helene which i personally think
is the best
redheads book like it's my that's just
not the
i would be so conflicted no that's okay
no and i already came to peace
that i was going to vote um for you
actually no but i don't want sympathy
votes that's the thing that's why i
didn't even want to address like i
didn't want i don't
you don't i want the redheads community
to like really i don't want to go with
their hearts
i don't want to win because i'm like
talking about it like i want to win
either because i deserve it and even if
i don't and i'm so proud to have made it
to the semifinals like and i really
really mean that
it truly is an honor to be nominated so
i didn't even want to like talk about it
because i don't want to sway
i really want people to vote with their
hearts like not with like you know
the stanhood of the toast so now my
prediction even though all my
predictions so far i've been wrong i do
think
i think it's going to come down to in
the finals girl with no job versus
before we were strangers
well that's that's so crazy like so
like little finals yeah and everybody
loves before we were strangers which was
a snitch's choice
has it been sweeping its own all the
yeah it's it's swept every category so
far but it hasn't gone up against
anything
too difficult yet i don't think so
whatever like even if i make it to the
finals like again please jump over me
just because
you like hear me saying it now if you've
read the book yeah
please vote keep the integrity of
redheads madness it's really important
to me like for real
yeah no and so far i feel like i think
there's definitely a lot of integrity
but i also think that um
some people tap through when they're
accidentally voting in the second i did
that
so for the next round i'm gonna move the
poll to the left so that we can have you
know more clarity
in the results or just make it a little
smaller i know but
yeah you know yeah no i i can i think
i'll be able to
achieve the integrity yeah um but you
guys some of like the fact that
husband's secret is beating my dark
vanessa like what i thought we all loved
my dark vanessa like no this is the
thing
reading is so personal it's personal as
food it's as personal as food and as
personal as comedy
yeah so it's highly interesting and
i think it will definitely instruct our
choices moving forward
you know it's like oh you guys just want
rom-coms all day right no
that's what i was saying like and that's
what i've learned you know i usually
like for the last
10 years the only books i've really read
are celebrity memoirs now getting into
this whole like non-fiction space
i've realized like wait non-fiction
right yep
um what people like fiction sure
what people like it's like romance
murder and sex like if you don't have
like at least
four like very erotic scenes in your
book like i don't want it no i know the
kids don't want it no colleen hoover
like she is literally like
writing these scenes i just followed her
on tick tock and i guess you never think
about like who the person writing is
because you just think from the
perspective of the narrator
but now that i know like colleen and
she's like a mom and she has kids like
i'm like
i cannot read these text scenes like i
know her no sometimes looking at the
author's instagram
is the worst thing the weirdest way to
ruin the book no
it supports like everything it just
depends on the the type of book but
sometimes it's just like what
no but also i really like following
colleen hoover on instagram
i mean on tick tock because she did like
a whole makeover of her
um like writing room and she has these
bookshelves that you need
for like the redheads like even in here
just to keep track
their dna bookshelves so they like
spiral up and they eventually when you
have them filled out look like
a dna spiral and it's like really cool
that's cool and but you
i mean you only have 18 books like i
think it's literally like 100 bucks per
we'll get there yeah you'll get there
it's never too late it's never too late
and considering that
it's clear that everybody loves the
snitch's choice this month is snitch's
choice christina lauren twice in a blue
moon like i think it's going to be like
before we were strangers vibes i think
people have already finished it and they
were like they loved it so
that will be really exciting makes it
the perfect time to become a redhead if
you are redhead please vote in the next
round of redheads madness coming to our
instagram stories today at like three
o'clock
one more thing so on friday's show we
were wrapping up and then we forgot like
that we had something to say
and we had a whole conversation like
after the wrap-up
and we said like we feel like nobody
hears us when
we um say something like that we forget
to say after the wrap up
and i have to say i got absolutely no
messages like
nobody heard the end of our episode oh i
saw a thread in toast after dark
and someone sent me today that their
screenshot of their podcast app where
every episode says like three minutes
left four minutes left
um they stopped listening most of them
but some people heard it enough to like
start a thread about it and talk about
when they stop listening so here's the
deal
people who listen on their phone on the
podcast app they end when we say that's
all she wrote
right by the way it's not over yet keep
it it's not over people who listen in
their car
they let it play out and then it queues
up into the next thing so i think if
you're listening i would say if you're
listening with airpods
you stop if you're listening like far
away
far away you just ride it out
interesting okay because like
i try to always you know get everything
in before the thank you too much
listening to the morning shows
but things happen things do happen and
usually we're pretty good about leaving
it all
behind us but i just thought i would get
a bunch of messages from people being
like no i listen to the last second
no no oh so since you're not listening
all the way to the end definitely
um go back to friday's episode oh no no
need we i think i was just giving a red
heads update oh
right i don't think you'd say probably
from that important no i was gonna say
so you never hear our sh
feel about like subscribing and leaving
a review and so oh yeah you should
listen but
you should definitely subscribe and
leave a five star review
and um head over to our patreon for more
premium content
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show
where we deliver the kids listening
where we live in the fast five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio catchbox all the places where
we listen to podcast
find out some morning chose to leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we
are
have a great day goodbye